Salut, nous sommes mercredi, il est 6h du matin, c'est le jour d'un nouveau casse tête pour cet été.
Et si vous voulez voir autre chose que des casse-têtes, activez la cloche,  je sors aussi des petites vidéos comme ça bonus, un petit peu sauvage. Alors aujourd'hui,
on va jouer avec ce robot... C'est un robot !
Qui est bourré d'élastiques et d'encoches ! Et le but de ce robot,
apparemment, c'est d'en faire un cube...
parfait. Voilà. De tout bouger pour en faire un cube parfait. Ca m'a pas l'air si simple parce qu'il y a des choses qui sont...
disproportionnées par rapport aux autres. En plus, j'ai de la chance, parce que j'ai un deuxième cerveau avec moi aujourd'hui : il s'agit de Céline H !
(CH) Deuxième cerveau ! Quand il s'agit de casse-tête...
L'autre jour, c'était Philippe Roche qui y a eu droit, là ce sera toi !
Breaking news ! Nous avons également un troisième cerveau, puisque Jeanne vient d'arriver aussi, puisque tout le monde passe ici apparemment, c'est comme ça...
Jeanne, si vous ne la connaissez pas, eh bien...
tu étais dans la 2e vidéo de ma chaîne, à savoir le 2 janvier 2016, je vous mets la fiche juste ici, et c'est un peu grâce à toi...
que j'ai fait des vidéos...
(J) Oh, arrête !
J'ai dis "un peu" *Rires*
Le but du jeu aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on a un robot, mais ce robot est un casse-  tête...
on est censé pouvoir faire un cube, un cube parfait, avec ça.
OK. Il ya des encoches, j'ai un peu étudié quand même le truc, il y a des encoches de partout avec toujours un élastique...
qu'on peut bouger d'encoche en encoche.
(J) OK, alors, c'est un cube sous quelle forme ? Carré ? Triangle ?
(CH) Un cube plutôt ovale. Mais je suis pas sûre...
Est-ce que c'est un cercle rond, ou pas ? *Rires*
(J) Quelle famille de cube, quoi...
Je pense que déjà, il faut qu'on se pose la question de...
combien de petits cubes il fait sur combien ?
Est ce que je suis clair ?
(CH) Mais est-ce qu'on est les meilleures invitées pour ce...
Vous êtes en tous cas celles qui êtes passées !
(CH) On est vraiment les invitées par défaut !
Je lui ai demandé si elle pouvait me ramener de l'aspirateur, elle a fait "oui", j'ai fait :
"je fais une vidéo en même temps". Après elle m'a dit "Y'a Jeanne qui arrive",
j'ai fait "Qu'elle reste aussi en même temps".
Pour l'instant, je sais pas si c'est un avantage ou un inconvénient.
(CH) Je pense que ça peut durer très longtemps.
1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 - 6
7 - 8 - 9 - 10 - 11 - 12 - 13 - 14 - 15 - 16 - 17... Je pense que c'est un cube de 3 sur 3.
(J) 3 x 3 neuf ? *Corbeaux*
Correct ! *Rires* ça y est on a résolu l'énigme !
(CH) Tu te sens pas un peu génius?!
Tu vois, je pense que ça fait 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 - 6 - 7 - 8 - 9 et ensuite encore au-dessus 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 - 6 - 7 -8 - 9
et encore au dessus 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 - 6 - 7 - 8 - 9 vous voyez ? C'est un peu comme des lasagnes...
qui ont 3 fois...
C'est clair ou pas du tout, non, en vrai ?
(CH) Si, des lasagnes, je vois bien ce que c'est.
Les lasagnes... Et le reste ?
(J) Absolument, mais...
Non c'est vrai ?
(CH) Non, pas du tout ! (J) On peut te soutenir par contre.
En fait, nous notre but, c'est d'en faire un cube.
Donc je pense qu'en terme de hauteur, il va y avoir 3 couches comme ça, sur 3 autres couches, puisque c'est un cube parfait.
(J) 3 x 3 !
Exact.
(J) Donc 9 cubes par surface.
(CH) Alors attends, tu sais, parce que moi je suis un petit peu...
tu vois, j'aime bien tâter, toucher / (J)T'as raison / j'aime bien, tu vois.
Humer la bête !
Alors...
Non mais moi je réfléchis à où est le piège, je pense que le piège, ça va être la tête, à placer,
parce qu'elle est décentrée, et elle fait pas la bonne taille.
(CH) Alors je fais rien du tout, je fais vraiment semblant ! *Rires*
C'est un casse-tête à tâtons. Là, par exemple, comme il y en a 2 et qu'on sait qu'on va vouloir en faire 3,
il faut faire des trucs un peu comme ça... Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
(J) Attends...
Mais tu vois ce que... Bon, là, ça marche pas mon histoire...
(J) Mais si ! Attends, regarde, attends !
(J) 1 - 2 - 3 - 1 - 2 - 3 - 1 - 2 - 3..
Oui mais il faut placer les bras, là, maintenant !
(CH) Tu fais n'importe quoi...
(J) Mais... Eh bien figure-toi que peut-être pas !
(CH) Est-ce que tu as conscience de ce que tu fais ?
Sûrement que oui ! *Rires*
(J) J'avais quand même l'impression de tenir un truc là !
Bah un robot...
(J) Attends... On pourrait être surpris !
Du temps de cette vidéo ? *Rires*
Surpris de la longueur !
(J) En fait non, je sais pas. (CH) Moi aussi, je sais pas, mais bien sûr...
Alors, pour saluer l'effort, vous avez quand même la chaîne de Jeanne qui apparaît juste au dessus de nous
Et tu relances tes vidéos... Tu viens de les relancer au début de l'été?
Absolument ! Je relance mes vidéos au début de l'été !
Alors pendant ce temps là, Céline H...
(CH) Tu peux m'appeler Céline...
(CH) Tu sais, Céline, finalement, c'est un petit peu mon prénom...
Ouais, mais c'est pas le nom de ta chaîne...
En même temps, quand je fais une vidéo...
avec Amixem, je dis pas "Maxime", je dis "Amixem".
(J) Absolument.
(CH) Bon ça va dis-donc la fayote là !
(J) Ecoute, c'est le langage YouTube.
(CH) Déjà, articule quand tu le dis !
(J) C'est le langage YouTube !
(CH) Alors déjà, c'est pas si mal... C'est pas bien !
(CH) Si je force bien comme ça !
(CH) Je vais y arriver si je force bien !
(CH) A faire un petit carré !
(J) Tu tiens le bon bout là.
(CH) Un petit carré, sa mère !
Tu sais que moi, ça m'aide, de vous voir le manipuler.
(CH) De voir tout ce qu'il y a pas à faire...
comme merde ?
(CH) Bien sûr !
(J) Eh oui, toi tu observes pendant ce temps. Donc quand tu vas le prendre, tu vas le faire en deux secondes...
Non ça je pense pas, mais du coup, ça me donne des idées quand même.
(CH) *chante* Laisse moi kiffer avec mon petit robot !
(CH) *chante* Tu sais, c'est beau, c'est par défaut !
Moi je fais les contres !
(CH) J'ai fait une petite crotte de chien !
(CH) Est-ce que c'est valable les petites crottes de chien ?
Je mets un sondage juste ici : "est ce que c'est valable, les petites crottes de chien ?"
Y'a un vrai sondage vous pouvez vraiment voter à cette question !
(J) Bon, écoute, Fabien, je retente une dernière fois puis après je pense que je te laisse le bébé !
(J) Tu vois, là, en soi, là on est pas mal...
Une petite fenêtre quoi...
Là ça fait 4 sur 3 surtout, donc on est plus sur un rectangle.
(J) Eh non ça fait 3 ! 1 - 2 - 3...
1 - 2 - 3 - 4
(J) Ah oui, on est d'accord !
Et le principe du carré...
(J) Oui, tu as raison.
(J) Putain ! Putain regarde !
(J) Qui dit quoi là ?
Colles-en encore 3 épaisseurs...
Je suis pas contre toi, je veux vraiment qu'on le réussisse.
(J) OK, OK, OK !
(CH) C'est tellement minable...
(J) Je sais pas...
(J) Vas-y Fabien, impressionne nous !
Y'a une chose qui est sûre,
quand je vous ai regardé faire, c'est que des fois, je trouvais qu'il y avait des pistes qui étaient pas mal, mais elle,
elle est complètement décentrée, la tête.
(J) Attends, qu'est-ce qui te fait dire ça ?
Regarde, elle est pas alignée avec l'élastique.
(J&CH) Ah oui d'accord !
Donc je pense que quoi, qu'on fasse, on va être emmerdé par elle, donc moi je propose de l'aligner comme ça.
(CH) C'est une proposition.
(CH) Mais moi j'aimerais pas trop rencontrer des gens qui sont carrément prêts à en faire une vidéo...
(J) Bah moi non plus !
(CH) Vraiment là, t'es un Nolife ! T'imagine, il manquerait plus qu'il y ait des gens qui participent à la vidéo ! *Rires*
(J) Là, alors eux, ils sont au bout de leur vie !
(J) Et puis imagine ceux qui regardent ! *Rires*
Alors moi, je m'en prends une dans chaque oreille... *Rires*
Suivant où on regarde, on peut avoir l'impression que ça prend forme, et en même temps, il y a plein de trucs qui vont pas.
(J) C'est vrai !
Franchement, ça prend forme quand même.
(CH) Mais on est quand même plus proche de tout ce qu'on a pu voir jusqu'à maintenant !
(J) Absolument !
(J) Entre la crotte de vanille et puis mon... *Rires*
(J) Mes petites plaques...
(CH) Plaques d'égout ! *Rires*
Je garde l'idée de départ de : il faut tâtonner. Tiens, regarde, ça c'est pas mal !
(CH) Ah, c'est très joli ! Avec la petite cheminée, c'est mignon même.
Le seul problème c'est que lui, il nous arrangerait plus ici.
(J) Ah, mais attends ! Est-ce qu'on peut pas...
On va pas pouvoir lui faire faire ce déplacement complet. Eh bah non !
(J) Ah non.
Parce qu'en fait, le principe de l'élastique, c'est qu'il touche toujours celui à qui il est attaché.
Comment on pourrait...
(J) Alors moi, à ce stade, je serais déjà tellement fière de moi que je laisserais comme ça, en disant que c'est une volonté de ma part...
d'avoir mis une cheminé
(CH) Bien sûr, c'est toujours un parti prix.
(CH) Absolument assumé !
(CH) C'est assumé !
(CH) Vos croyances sont erronées de penser que je mets pas...
(J) Vous pensez que je suis conforme mais non, je suis...
un anticonformiste, je suis un anarchiste !
(CH) Evidemment !
Après, sinon, moi je propose qu'on fasse comme ça.
(J&CH) Mais non ! Bravo ! *Applaudissements*
Et bien voilà, nous avons un cube !
Je crois que c'est hyper motivant, parce que comme je veux que ça s'arrête...
*Rires*
Non mais en vrai, ce qui m'a aidé, c'était de vous voir le manipuler avant.
(CH) Bravo ! (J) C'est impressionnant !
C'est cool. Ecoute, si tu veux, je te laisse le plaisir d'essayer.
Comme dans tout bon casse-tête, quand on fait un sens, il faut être capable de faire l'autre sens. Essaye de refaire le robot,
je te jure que ça devrait bien se passer.
(J) C'est plus facile ça, non ? Il se remet pas tout seul ?
Moi je propose que tu laisses à Jeanne le soin de terminer. Là il est quand même tombé de 10 mètres de haut !
On voit que c'est un robot, mais on voit qu'il a eu mal.
(J) Bah qu'est-ce qui t'es arrivé ? *Rires*
(J) Ça c'est la petite jambe, et bah voilà !
(J) Et ça c'est le petit bras ! Eh bah non... Eh bah si !
(CH) Et bah c'est le kiki ! C'est le petit kiki ! *Rires*
(J) Eh bah dis donc ! Qu'est-ce qu'il fait au niveau de l'épaule ce kiki ? *Rires*
(J) Mais pourquoi il est... Mais putain !  Ah ! Et puis là...
On est presque bon là
(J) Ca va être la petite jambe ! Eh bah voilà ! Eh bah voilà....
(CH) Regardez-moi ça...  Bravoooo !
(J) C'est moi qui l'ai fait !
Bravo ! *Applaudissements* Jeanne, Céline, toutes mes félicitations !
(CH) Fabien, extraordinaire !
(J) Fabien, fabuleux, comme d'habitude. Là, vraiment, tu ne nous déçoit pas !
Ça part dans le décor du coup !
Et... Ça vous a plu ?
(J) C'était vachement bien !
Moi je vais en faire plein des comme ça encore cet été.
(CH) C'est vrai ?
Je n'avais pas prévu de faire celui là aujourd'hui, mais du coup comme tu étais là, et puis après Jeanne est arrivée, je trouvais ça plus sympa,
le robot.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo ! N'hésitez pas à vous abonner à mon Instagram ou à son Instagram,
ou à sa chaîne Youtube, ou à sa chaîne Youtube. Bref, gardons le contact durant l'été. Mais moi je fais des vidéo en ce moment sur Instagram.
(CH) Et ça c'est sympa, et c'est divertissant ! Ça plait.
Ça plaît beaucoup, moi je marche dans la rue on me dit "ça nous plaît".
(J) Ah mais bien sûr, ça faut vraiment le coup d’œil. Moi je passe ma vie dessus ! J'arrête pas de les regarder !
(F) mais tu es une mytho, tu n'as même pas instagram !
*Rires* (CH) T'as même pas Instagram !
Likez la vidéo si ça vous a plu. A très bientôt, mercredi prochain au plus tard. Ciao ! (CH&J) Ciao !